- I know, you know, reality
shows don't get the respect
that I believe they deserve.
- Why do you think people
sign up to watch you?
- I think because I am so open.
My smartest business decision
has been going for it
and not, like, having no fear.
When you do take time for
yourself, that's when like,
the magic happens, and these ideas come.
(swooshes)
- Hello, believe nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is, believe, and I believe
in people more than they
believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey
today, we're going to learn
from entrepreneur, actress,
and TV personality,
Kim Kardashian, and my take on
her top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with
you, please leave it down
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(swooshes)
(sweeping instrumental music)
(beeps)
- Do you think that
people underestimate you,
underestimate how much
you work on this stuff,
underestimate your intelligence,
and my question is,
is that something you push back on
or something you leverage?
- Definitely something
that doesn't bother me.
- [Host] Okay.
- When someone underestimates me,
I love to get to know
them and have them have
one conversation with
me to just understand
that it's, I mean, I think
the easiest question to ask
is what does she do?
What is her talent?
You know?
And I jokingly said, actually
to my husband, the other day,
I said, you know what?
My next answer should
be like, sarcastically,
how lucky am I?
If I don't sing and I
don't dance, but I'm still
doing what I'm doing, how easy is my job?
I don't have to do any of that.
I don't have to be onstage
like you working so hard,
but we're still driving the same car.
We're still living the
same life, you know.
(audience laughs)
So, lucky me, you know,
if it was that easy.
(audience applauds)
But, you know, I think
it's just the like the
easiest thing to ask.
For anyone to really assume
that it's not a full time job
to have to sit and
create things and come up
with every single blog post,
and I do, you know, three a day
and having to, you know, working on apps?
It's, to me it would be the
same thing as people saying
like, anything blogging.
Like, what do you do?
You're sitting at home in your apartment,
and you're just on the computer.
Like, that is such hard work.
- I think people do
say those things about us.
- I respect it so much, you know.
- Yeah.
- And they say that
about the modeling world.
Well, they just sit there looking pretty.
It is a full time job for,
you know, models like,
you know, my sister even, Kendall.
It's, I don't mind getting underestimated,
but I feel for people
that, I understand how it
could bother them if they were
put in the same situation.
Even filming a reality show.
It's a full time job.
I mean, I think that, I
know reality shows don't get
the respect that I believe they deserve,
and that's why I love
being on one for so long,
and I will always fight to
be on as long as possible
'cause I love to show and prove.
But my personality is just
if you underestimate me,
I would love to have a
conversation with you.
I would love to, I just
like to prove people wrong.
- Why do you think people
sign up to watch you?
- I think because I am so open.
- [Host] Right.
- You know, I think--
- Now, you do these yourself.
You said this.
- [Kim] Yes.
- Absolutely.
- [Kim] Yes, I don't.
- You don't have a team
of people chasing you.
I didn't see any chasing you around.
- No, I don't have a team.
I love to, if the whole connection is me
with other people, I
don't want someone else,
It makes no sense to have that connection.
- Did you think about that?
- [Kim] No.
- You were puzzled when I said there
were people that had that.
- Yeah.
- You don't have anybody doing
any of your social media?
- No, no, that doesn't make sense.
- What have you found in
these new platforms and tools,
and you've articulated
how each one is different
and how you see each one
meeting a certain purpose.
What have you found has
worked, and what have you found
hasn't worked from all of that experience?
- I think that doing
anything and everything,
and I'm guilty of that before,
people probably won't believe you.
And you probably don't even
really grasp what like,
now, if I'm going to promote
something, I have to use it.
I have to like it.
I have to be active with it.
I want to know the
partners, and I want to know
who owns the company.
I want to know so much
about it, and I love to be
loyal to that company and just
do what's authentic to me.
But I tried so many things in the past,
and I think through
all of that experience,
you just learn what you
like and what you love.
But I think the key on social
media is just being authentic.
My smartest business decision
has been going for it
and not being, like, having no fear.
And just even if they
failed and even if it hasn't
turned out the way that I
want it, I've learned so much
from it, so my advice would be go for it.
- Everything's about learning experience.
- Totally.
- Is there something, like a
specific example you can give
that maybe wasn't the
smartest business decision
or something that you
did that you're like,
oh, okay, I could've
done this differently?
- Back in the day, I used to
just be involved with so much.
- [Interveiwer] Yeah.
- Whether it was like
tanning or shoes, you know--
- Throwing your name on everything.
- Shoe dazzle, which, I
loved the process of it all,
but, you know, being a cupcake,
sponsor to a cupcake store.
I mean, everything, but
throwing myself into everything
taught me everything I know now,
so I wouldn't take any of it back.
I pride myself in my work ethic.
I work really hard, so I
think that, you know, I think
that sometimes when people
hear that I might have gotten
success off of a reality show.
- Right.
- They take that as a negative.
So I think that I, you
know, we're filming our 10th
season right now, and we've
had, I think nine seasons
of spinoffs, so our show, I mean,
we have more episodes than I Love Lucy.
I mean, we have so many amazing milestones
that people don't really
stop and think about.
People don't understand.
When you are, even though
it is reality, I wake up
every single day at six a.m.,
and you know, go to the gym
and you know, get my
daughter up, feed my baby,
get ready, film all day,
sometimes don't finish
until, you know, eight or nine p.m.,
and that's every single
day, six days a week
for five months straight
when we're filming.
And so that in itself is a full time job
mixed in with, you know,
every other project
that we're working on, and I
just, unfortunately, I just
don't think reality TV gets
the respect that it deserves.
- What did you imagine,
what did you what to be
when you grew up?
- When I was about 13-years-old,
I looked at my best friend,
and the show Real World had just come out.
And so I said to her, oh, my gosh.
That's what I want to do.
I want to be on a reality show.
- [Host] Wow.
- And you have to be my manager.
And she looked at me
and said, well, I said,
we both have to audition
for The Real World.
Let's make a tape when we're 18.
We'll send it in to the producers.
And we have to do this
show called The Real World.
She was like, you can do it.
Not a chance for me.
I'll be your manager.
And you, you know, we'll
make a tape for you.
So it's just like such
a full circle moment,
'cause she's a manager now.
She's in the management
business, and my show is produced
by the people that did The Real World.
I just thought our family life
has always been interesting.
It's never a dull moment.
Everyone that came into
our life said, oh, my gosh.
I can't believe you guys aren't on TV.
Or I can't believe your family
isn't a sitcom or something
since reality TV wasn't so popular then.
So it's just, I mean, I
did have a clothing store,
which I still have today,
Dash, that, you know,
was fashion, when I was in high school,
I worked at a clothing store.
So if that didn't pan out, if
The Real World didn't pan out
then fashion is really
what I wanted to get into.
And I, you know I worked at,
you know, the clothing store.
And my sisters and I opened one up.
And so I thought that's
where I was going to be
and that's what I was going to be doing.
You know, I thing that
my mom and my grandmother
have always been really good role models.
My mom is really strong.
I think she's had to deal
with a lot in her life.
And she always puts on a
brave face and always wants
everyone to feel
comfortable and confident,
and I really admire that in her.
- How do you find time to
brainstorm where you can just shut
everything out and take
a pause and say, okay,
maybe I ought to reexamine this?
- Well, I think when you,
I do take time for myself,
and I think that's very important.
And even going to Japan and
seeing so many amazing things.
I got so many great ideas,
and when you do take time
for yourself, that's when
like the magic happens,
and these ideas come.
And I think no matter who
you are or what you do,
if you don't take time for yourself,
you can never rejuvenate,
and you can never get back
that creative spark.
So I do take time off, and
I do get a lot of ideas
from my travels and
just being around people
that give me ideas and inspire me.
So I think that is really important.
And I wake up in the middle
of the night sometimes
with these ideas, and I'll
just send it to my team,
and hopefully, not wake them all up
in the middle of the night.
In business, I love looking
at my peers and seeing that,
you know, young, successful
women like Jessica Alba.
You know, I spoke to her this
morning, and we were just
picking each other's brains on something.
Like, I love her dedication,
and she's always been someone
that I've looked up to business-wise.
She's just a really smart girl.
I call, I like to surround
myself with people
that I can always call for advice.
You know, my best friend
who is now in the management
business has now gone into
like, product placement
business and started a company
on her own, and it's been
fascinating to see her
build her brand and her business.
One of my other best friends,
two of them were in publicity
for a long time, so I
like to pick their brains
on, you know, perception of things.
You know, I just love to
surround myself with people
that I can call and get good
advice from all the time.
I think it's really important.
- She had a terrible time.
She came in for Paris Fashion Week.
And she ended up being
tied up to furniture
with a gun pointed at her
head in her luxury apartments.
- Hey, I want to talk to
you about the Paris incident
because I know you did an
episode on the show about it.
- Yeah.
- And I haven't spoken to you since then.
- I had your family members
on, but I think that,
I don't know that everybody
understands how horrific
that experience must have been for you.
- Yeah, I mean, I know this sounds crazy,
but I know that was meant to happen to me.
I like, don't want to
start crying, but like,
I feel like that was so
meant to happen to me.
Like, I'm such a different person.
And like, I'm, I just don't
want to start crying anymore,
but yeah, I--
- [Ellen] You can cry.
I mean--
- It was meant to happen to me.
Like, the things, I really
feel like things happen
in your life to teach you things.
- [Ellen] Yeah.
- And this was like, I'm just--
(audience applauds)
- Thanks.
Like, I was, you know, it
was probably no secret.
You see it on the show
and us being flashy.
Like, I was definitely
materialistic before,
and not that there's anything
bad with having things
and working hard to get those things,
and I'm really proud of,
you know, everyone around me
that's successful, but like,
I'm so happy that my kids
get this me, and that this
who I'm raising my kids,
I just don't care about
that stuff anymore.
- [Ellen] Really?
Wow.
- I really don't.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
I mean, like I said,
everyone gets so excited.
- [Audience] Aw.
- Yeah, when they get
things, or of course,
when you get engaged, you're
going to show off your ring.
People, if they get a new car,
I don't care what kind it is.
You get so proud, and you get so happy,
and you show that off on social media.
But it's just, it's not worth it.
Like, I don't care about that stuff.
I don't care to show off
like, the way that I used to
even though there's nothing, truly,
like, it's okay if you're
proud of that, you know.
And you work so hard
and you get something.
It's just not who I am anymore.
- So you were in, because you
were showing these diamonds
because you were in Paris.
- [Kim] Yeah.
- You showed off what you had.
- Yeah.
- And you think that that
attracted those guys,
and they said, she has
all this in her apartment.
- Yeah.
- And I'm just trying to understand.
So, because I can't imagine
being, you were alone.
- [Kim] Yeah.
- And it's what time is this?
- It was about, almost
like 2:30 in the morning,
but what was crazy is
meeting with my attorneys
and knowing the information
that I know now.
They had been following me for two years.
And they had been hearing
interviews that I did
getting excited about this
jewelry or this jewelry,
and saying that it's, you know, real.
And that's not to say that
I'll never wear jewelry again
or anything like that.
I truly don't know if I'd
ever feel comfortable.
ever wear real jewelry again.
I, you know, just my whole life
has changed as far as like,
how I travel and what, you know, security.
I never thought that I needed
security staying outside
my door even though I
had a lot of jewelry,
and if you think about it.
Yeah, I should have had a
security guard outside my door
24/7 when I'm traveling.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't.
Now, I have several.
- Yeah.
- You know, just to be
able to sleep at night.
- But how did they get in?
The door was locked right?
- Yes, the door was locked.
I didn't answer the door.
They held a gun up to the
concierge that was downstairs,
and said, let us up to,
where's the rapper's wife?
And then--
- How dare them not know your name.
(audience laughs)
- And yep.
- All right, so let us
up to the rapper's wife.
- So yeah, they led him up to the room,
and he opened the door for them,
handcuffed, but open the door.
- So he must have called
the police right away once,
or did they probably held
onto him, so he couldn't
call the police.
- They had like handcuffed
him and tied him up
in the stairwell, so he couldn't, so
when they left, I--
- Were you awake, or were you asleep?
- I was just about to fall
asleep, but I was awake.
- So you heard people in there.
- I heard people running up the stairs.
I thought it was my sister
and my friend, drunk,
coming home, and I was
calling out for them.
Like, I debated going out, not
going out, like, all night.
And then, finally, I'm
like, you know what?
I'm just going to stay in and pack.
And one of my high school
friends who's a stylist
that came with us on
that trip was downstairs
in a bedroom, and they didn't know
that she was there with us.
So she heard what was going
on, and she heard me screaming.
And so she called my
sister and my security.
- But, okay, so let's
get, they're with you.
- Yeah.
- They have a gun.
- Are you hysterically crying?
Are you, like, how do you
react in a situation like that?
- Automatically, you
know, your stomach drops.
It's a feeling you can't even explain,
and you, like, I knew that was it for me.
- [Ellen] You thought
you were going to die?
- 100%, 100%, I said a prayer.
I'm like, I know I'm going to heaven.
I hope my kids are okay, my husband.
I don't want to cry.
You're making me cry.
- [Audience] Aw.
- But, you know, it
does happen really fast.
It was a good like seven or
eight minutes of like, torture,
but when I look back, and
I analyze it, I'm like,
okay, they weren't really, like
it could have been way worse.
So I don't want to sound, you
know, like I'm not grateful.
I'm out.
I'm home.
I'm safe.
- [Ellen] Yeah.
- I'm such a better person.
I'm, it's okay.
Like, let's move on.
- [Ellen] Yeah.
(swooshes)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Christopher Sumlin asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below,
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to 2,000 Books.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word and doing
that fun interview together
on your YouTube channel.
I really, really, really
appreciate you support,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the read.
- Today, we have Evan
Carmichael, my mentor,
and we're talkin' about his
awesome book, Your One Word.
- Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swooshes)
- I've always been, I've
always just been open.
- [Host] Right.
- I've always been
super open with my life,
and that's just who I am.
And it's worked out 'cause
that's how my family is, too,
so we can be really candid.
And it's kind of the
irony 'cause my husband
is completely the opposite.
You know, he doesn't have Instagram.
- And yet we know so much about him now.
He's all over Instagram with you.
- Yeah.
- In closing, when you
appeared on the cover
of Forbes a year ago, you tweeted,
"Not bad for a girl with no talent."
Which is quite an irony given the obvious
talents that you have.
- Oh, thank you.
- What do you say to those
who downplay or dismiss
your success, or you just have the feeling
that success is the best revenge?
Are you able to be like the duck
and just let it roll off the back?
- I do let it roll off my back.
I do feel like success is
the best revenge, absolutely.
To say that I'm not human,
for people to always say
crazy, mean things, I mean,
it definitely does get to me.
I think that I've, with
the support of my family,
we've always kind of come
through on the other side.
But to write that, I
remember I was thinking,
do I want, you don't want
to be boastful and say,
I'm on the cover of Forbes.
This is so amazing.
Which you do want to say, but of course,
people would be, say
something negative about that,
so I thought it was funny
just the little hashtag
for people that might
question how I got here
or what talent I have.
I was like, I'm on the cover of Forbes.
So I must be doing something right.
(laughs)
I love sharing, but I do
think there are limits to it,
and I think you have to have boundaries.
- Well, do you have any?
What are your boundaries?
- I do. I do.
I, (audience laughs) it
took me a while to get
to share things with my daughter.
I was really hesitant
about that for a while.
And I still don't post
all the things that we do
on a daily basis where I
see some of my friends.
They're Instagrams are all their children.
So I am, you know, protective over that.
I am protective over my
relationship sometimes
with oversharing about that
'cause I've made mistakes.
And I think overshared in the past.
- [Host] Yes, yes.
- Which I think sometimes could be
just it didn't work out for me that way.
So I felt like I would try--
- Any particular sharing
that you'd like to take back?
- I'm sure.
I'd have to look at some things.
Even some, I love hair and
makeup and the glam process,
and I share a lot about
that and tips and tricks.
I'm fascinated by the beauty blogger space
and YouTube and how so many
different beauty bloggers
have, you know, risen to fame
just off of their tutorials.
I look at them.
We do fun tutorials all the
time, me and my makeup artist
and hairstylist, so there's
probably some glam moments
where I thought, what was I thinking,
and why am I wearing that color lipstick?
Why did I post that?
(swooshes)